Tom Hodgson's one of those "get tough on crime" politicians, a Republican who was appointed to the job of sheriff by a Republican governor. And as soon as he became sheriff in Bristol County, Massachusetts, he went right to work in the county jail.
Tom Hodgson 是那种“严惩犯罪”的政客，一位共和党人，被共和党州长任命为警长。他在马萨诸塞州布里斯托县一担任警长，就立刻着手整顿县监狱。
Before he came, we had no control over this jail. The inmates had control of the jail. He changed all that.
在他来之前，我们对监狱毫无控制力。囚犯们控制着监狱。他改变了这一切。
Carlos Carrero has worked in the jail for 10 years. He says Sheriff Hodgson imposed discipline on the inmates and the guards. He changed the rules so that inmates had to go into classes or activities if they wanted their time counted as good time. He removed the TVs from the cells, removed the weight room. Carlos gestures around his own office.
Carlos Carrero 在监狱工作了 10 年。他说 Hodgson 警长对囚犯和狱警都实施了严格的纪律管理。他修改了规定，要求囚犯必须参加课程或活动才能获得减刑。他移除了牢房里的电视和健身房。Carlos 在他的办公室周围比划着。
As a matter of fact, this office right here, this used to be a weight room, right here we were are. He removed all that, because to him, it made no sense for us to make people charged with crimes, to make them even stronger than when they came in.
事实上，这间办公室以前就是健身房。他把那些设备都拆了，因为在他看来，让那些被指控犯罪的人变得比进来时更强壮，是完全没有意义的。
I remember before him that we used to have requests every single day from different institutions, of inmates who wanted to come to this institution. This was vacation ground. This was where they could do whatever they want. Everything was going fine. Now it's the other way around. Everybody wants to leave this jail. They don't want to stay here. It's a very strict institution within the laws.
我记得在他来之前，每天都有不同的机构提出请求，希望能把囚犯送到我们这里。这里简直是度假村。他们可以为所欲为。一切都很好。现在情况完全反过来了。每个人都想离开这所监狱。他们不想待在这里。这是一个在法律范围内非常严格的机构。
But not long after Sheriff Hodgson took office in 1997, Carlos Carrero started to tell him about something going on at the jail that seemed terribly unfair. There was a new immigration law put into place just a year before, which was sentencing lots of people to deportation who had never been eligible for deportation before this. Here's Sheriff Hodgson.
但 Hodgson 警长 1997 年上任后不久，Carlos Carrero 就开始向他反映监狱里发生的一些非常不公平的事情。前一年刚出台了一项新的移民法，导致许多以前从未面临遣返的人被判遣返。听听 Hodgson 警长的说法。
When I took over this job-- obviously one of the things that is fundamental whenever you're in public office is to make sure that the scales of justice are properly balanced. So if I see that somehow the law is being applied in an unbalanced way, then shame on me if I don't stand up and try to correct that. First of all, there were certain offenses-- drunk driving, for example-- that prior to '96 was not a deportable offense, that today would be a deportable offense.
当我接手这份工作时——显然，担任公职的人最基本的一点就是要确保天平的平衡。所以，如果我发现法律的执行方式失衡，如果我不站出来试图纠正它，那就是我的失职。首先，有些罪行——例如酒驾——在 96 年之前还不是可遣返罪行，但现在却成了可遣返罪行。
In fact, any crime that got a sentence of a year in length was suddenly bad enough to get you deported if you didn't have full citizenship-- drunk driving, petty theft, minor drug possession charges. All of these could suddenly get a person deported. But what made this especially severe was that it was retroactive. If you committed these crimes decades ago, served your time, been a model community member ever since, suddenly you could be thrown out of the country.
事实上，任何被判处一年徒刑的犯罪，如果你没有完全的公民身份，突然间就足以让你被遣返了——酒驾、小偷小窃、轻微毒品持有指控。所有这些突然间都能导致一个人被遣返。但最严酷的是这项法律具有追溯力。如果你几十年前犯了这些罪，服完了刑，此后一直是一名模范社区成员，你可能会突然被逐出这个国家。
If, for example, someone, say, when they were 20 years old, was arrested for drunk driving, got a year, either probation or jail, finished their probation-- it was the only run-in with the law they had. And then at 24 years old, he decides to get married. Has a job, responsible, pays taxes, has a couple of children. And now, the kids are four and five years old. The '96 law kicks in, the change in the law. The person decides, my son's three years old, my daughter's now five. I'm going to go ahead and get my citizenship.
如果一个人，比如说，他在 20 岁时因酒驾被捕，被判了一年，无论是缓刑还是监禁，服完缓刑后——这是他唯一一次触犯法律。然后在 24 岁时，他决定结婚。有了工作，负责任，纳税，还有几个孩子。现在，孩子四岁和五岁了。96 年的法律生效了，法律变更了。这个人想，我儿子三岁，我女儿现在五岁。我还是去申请公民身份吧。
Or perhaps they heard about the changes in the law and thought, hey, the country is getting tougher on green card holders. I should finally get my full citizenship. And they head down to the immigration service to do that.
或者他们可能听说了法律的变更，想道，嘿，国家对绿卡持有者越来越严了。我应该最终获得我的正式公民身份。于是他们前往移民局办理。
When they get there, voluntarily, to apply, they run their background check and find out that 15 years earlier, this person got arrested for drunk driving. INS says, I'm sorry, we're shipping you back to wherever. That to me is a law that clearly is unfair. The person had done their time. They'd volunteered to go get their citizenship, and here, now, they're being taken away from their family.
当他们自愿去申请时，移民局进行了背景调查，发现这个人 15 年前因酒驾被捕。移民局说，抱歉，我们要把你遣返回原籍地。这在我看来显然是不公平的法律。这个人已经服过刑了。他们自愿去申请公民身份，结果现在却被带离了他们的家人。
And so this law-and-order Republican has found himself in the position of calling for Congress to change a law that he thinks is too harsh. He's traveled to Washington DC to lobby legislators. And for the people in his jail who are awaiting deportation, he's brought in teachers to prepare them for their new lives overseas.
于是，这位主张法律与秩序的共和党人发现自己处于要求国会修改一项他认为过于严苛的法律的位置。他前往华盛顿特区去游说立法者。对于他监狱里等待遣返的人，他请来老师帮助他们为海外的新生活做准备。
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
[葡萄牙语演讲]
Bristol County happens to be home to a large Portuguese population, which has seen over 400 people deported in the last four years under this new law. On any given date, 35 to 40 people are being held in the county jail, most of them waiting to be deported back to Portugal.
布里斯托县恰好居住着大量葡萄牙裔，在这项新法律下，过去四年里已有超过 400 人被遣返。在任何时候，都有 35 到 40 人被关押在县监狱，他们大多数都在等待被遣返回葡萄牙。
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
[葡萄牙语演讲]
Mario Medeiros drops some Portuguese money onto a desk for four inmates and explains to them how much each coin and bill is worth in the country that they will soon be deported to, for most of them a country they haven't even seen since they were small children. The whole thing's done in Portuguese so they can get some practice. Some need it more than others. Most of them don't even remember seeing this money before.
Mario Medeiros 把一些葡萄牙货币扔在桌上给四名囚犯看，并向他们解释每种硬币和纸币在他们即将被遣返的国家值多少钱。对他们大多数人来说，那个国家是他们小时候之后就再没见过的。这一切都用葡萄牙语完成，这样他们可以练习一下。有些人比其他人更需要练习。他们中大多数人甚至不记得见过这种钱。
Yeah, that's totally new to me. Yeah, totally new.
是的，对我来说完全是新鲜的。是的，完全新鲜。
Jorge Aruda expects to be shipped overseas any day now.
Jorge Aruda 预计随时会被遣送到海外。
Weird-looking money. It's all different colors, and coins. I'm used to an American dollar bill, you know?
看起来很奇怪的钱。颜色各异，还有硬币。我习惯了美元，你知道吗？
I am lost with that.
我对那完全摸不着头脑。
Jorge Aruda came to America when he was two years old. Now he's 25. He's no angel. He was addicted to heroin. While robbing a store, he got into a fight with an off-duty cop. It was the second time he was convicted of an assault charge, and he was sentenced to a year, which he served. That was enough to result in deportation under the '96 law.
Jorge Aruda 两岁时来到美国。现在他 25 岁。他不是天使。他曾沉迷于海洛因。在抢劫一家商店时，他与一名休班警察发生了争执。这是他第二次因袭击罪被定罪，被判了一年刑，他也服刑了。根据 96 年的法律，这足以导致遣返。
Do you feel like you shouldn't have been punished?
你觉得你不应该受到惩罚吗？
I feel like I should have been punished somewhat, but not punished for the rest of my life. That's how I take it. That was a life sentence for me. They've punished me for the rest of my life. I feel there's no need for it. If someone pays-- if someone does their time, is committed to any kind of sentence for what they've done, then that should be their punishment. That's it. Let him go home. He's done. He's paid for what he's done. Let him go home to his family. Why ship me out of the country?
我觉得我应该受到某种惩罚，但不应该被惩罚一辈子。这就是我的感受。对我来说，那是终身监禁。他们惩罚了我一辈子。我觉得没必要这样。如果一个人付出了代价——如果一个人为自己的行为服了刑，完成了任何判决，那么那应该是他们的惩罚。就是这样。让他回家吧。他已经付出了代价。让他回家回到家人身边。为什么要将我逐出国境？
Jorge will be sent to a part of Portugal where his family's from, where he has godparents and an aunt, all elderly.
Jorge 将被遣送到葡萄牙他家人的所在地，那里有他的教父母和一位姑姑，都已年迈。
What do you picture when you picture what it's like there?
当你想象那里的生活时，你脑海中是什么样子？
What do I picture? We've seen a video here of how it was out there. And it's like a country life, you know? I've lived in the city all my life. You know what I mean? I'm watching this video and there's people riding on donkeys and milking cows and stuff, you know? That's something I've never done. I drink milk from the fridge and I ride around in a car. I can't picture myself on a donkey and milking cows, you know? It's going to be hard to adapt. But I guess I've got no choice but to get used to it.
我脑海中是什么样子？我们在这里看过关于那里的录像。感觉就像农村生活，你知道吗？我这辈子一直生活在城市里。你明白我的意思吗？我看那个录像，有人骑着驴，有人挤牛奶之类的，你知道吗？那是我从未做过的事。我从冰箱里拿牛奶喝，开着车到处跑。我无法想象自己骑驴或挤牛奶，你知道吗？去适应会很难。但我猜我没得选择，只能去习惯它。
Today on our program, the story of a little-known law and how it has affected one community in Massachusetts. We live in a big enough country that there are actually lots of laws too obscure for most of us to have heard of, which actually affect tens of thousands of lives in huge, huge ways. Today we hear about one of them. It's an immigration law that the immigration service itself says is unfair. Most of  the law's original sponsors in Congress now say they went too far, they were too harsh when they passed the law, and yet most of the law's key provisions still stand unchanged and unchallenged. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
今天我们的节目讲述的是一项鲜为人知的法律，以及它如何影响了马萨诸塞州的一个社区。我们生活在一个足够大的国家，有很多法律对我们大多数人来说太过生僻，但它们在巨大的程度上影响着成千上万人的生活。今天我们来听听其中之一。这是一项连移民局自己都认为不公平的移民法。国会中大多数该法律的原始提案人现在都说他们做得太过分了，通过法律时太严苛，然而该法律的大多数关键条款仍然未作改变，也没有受到质疑。来自芝加哥 WBEZ 和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。
Act One of our show today, Where Goes the Neighborhood? We hear how the immigration law of 1996 has a community of nonpolitical people reluctantly going to protests, attending meetings at night, talking to politicians, doing all sorts of things most of us would do anything to avoid.
今天我们节目的第一幕，“邻里何去何从？”我们听听 1996 年的移民法是如何让一群非政治性的人不情愿地去参加抗议、晚上参加会议、与政客交谈、做各种我们大多数人会竭力避免的事情。
Act Two, Whose Idea Was This Anyway? Congressman Barney Frank argues that most of his colleagues had no idea what they were voting for when they voted for key portions of this law, and an advocate for the law explains why we should want to deport more people.
第二幕，“这到底是谁的主意？”国会议员 Barney Frank 认为，他的大多数同事在投票支持这项法律的关键部分时，根本不知道自己在投什么，而该法律的一位拥护者则解释了为什么我们应该希望遣返更多的人。
Act Three, Man Without a Country. What happens if the immigration service wants to deport you, but the country that you come from won't take you back. Under current law, usually, you stay in jail indefinitely. Alex Kotlowitz tells the story from Texas. It is an action-packed hour. Stay with us.
第三幕，“没有国家的男人”。如果移民局想要遣返你，但你来自的国家不接受你，会发生什么？根据现行法律，通常情况下，你会无限期留在监狱里。Alex Kotlowitz 讲述了发生在德克萨斯州的故事。这是充满行动力的一小时。请继续收听。
Act One, Where Goes the Neighborhood. When the 1996 immigration law kicked into effect, the number of people deported because of their criminal past doubled from about 30,000 people a year to about 60,000. Two towns in Massachusetts, Fall River and New Bedford, were especially hard-hit because of the large Portuguese community there, which includes many newcomers and which mostly comes from the Portuguese island called the Azores. This American Life producer Blue Chevigny spent some time there recently talking to people about the effects of the law.
第一幕，邻里何去何从。1996 年移民法生效时，因犯罪记录被遣返的人数从每年约 3 万人增加到约 6 万人。马萨诸塞州的两个城镇，福尔里弗和新贝德福德，受到的打击尤为严重，因为那里有大量的葡萄牙社区，包括许多新移民，他们大多来自名为亚速尔群岛的葡萄牙岛屿。《美国生活》制作人 Blue Chevigny 最近在那里待了一段时间，与人们谈论该法律的影响。
Mario Fredas is the kinds of dad who has learned to tune out the fact that there's a five-year-old, a one-and-a-half-year-old, and a recently-born baby all wanting attention as he tries to talk to me in his living room. He came to this country 19 years ago, when he was 17, from the Azores, the islands off of Portugal. He and his wife Maria show me pictures, one from 1980.
Mario Fredas 是那种学会了忽视五个孩子、一岁半的孩子和刚出生的婴儿都在渴望关注的事实的父亲，因为他正试着在客厅跟我谈话。他 19 年前从亚速尔群岛——葡萄牙外海的岛屿——来到这个国家，当时他 17 岁。他和妻子 Maria 向我展示照片，其中一张是 1980 年的。
That was when we came to this country.
那时我们来到这个国家。
Who are these?
这些是谁？
This is me. This is my older brother. And this was a friend of us who was already here. He's from Boston.
这是我。这是我哥哥。这是我们的一位朋友，他已经在这里了。他是波士顿人。
Hey, Daddy. That's Uncle Tony.
嘿，爸爸。那是托尼叔叔。
Yes.
是的。
Mario is like most of the people in this community who face deportation under the '96 immigration law. They came here from Portugal in the '70s as children with their families to escape the Salazar dictatorship. They were legal immigrants with green cards. Typically they got involved with drugs or alcohol and got in trouble with the law for drunk driving, drug possession, domestic violence, and minor assault charges. Mario was convicted of cocaine possession with intent to distribute when he was 24. He served a three-year sentence. He was released in 1991. Then, after his parole, he didn't think about his crime all that much until one morning last year.
Mario 和这个社区里大多数面临 1996 年移民法遣返的人一样。他们 70 年代作为孩子随家人从葡萄牙来到这里，为了逃避萨拉查独裁统治。他们是持有绿卡的合法移民。通常他们因为酒驾、毒品持有、家庭暴力和小规模袭击等指控触犯了法律。Mario 在 24 岁时因意图分发可卡因被定罪。他服刑了三年。他在 1991 年获释。之后，在缓刑期结束后，他并没有太在意自己的罪行，直到去年的一天早上。
I was going to work. I work in Boston. Just a regular day. I get up. I get [INAUDIBLE].
我正要去上班。我在波士顿工作。只是普通的一天。我起床。我...[听不清]。
We walk outside.
我们走到外面。
And I just get in my truck over here. I just went inside. I've got my coffee, my bagel. Just on my mind is getting to work, make some money. I back it up, just like a regular back-up. When I reach to that car right there--
我上了那边的卡车。我刚进去。我拿了咖啡和百吉饼。心里只想着去上班，赚点钱。我倒车，就像平常一样倒车。当我到达那辆车的时候——
He points to a car half a block away.
他指向半个街区外的一辆车。
That's about, what, 150 feet? I see a police car coming from the corner where you see that tree, coming this way.
那是，大概，150英尺？我看到一辆警车从你看到那棵树的拐角处过来，朝这个方向驶来。
He pulled over, thinking the police were there for someone else. And suddenly officers appeared on both sides of this truck.
他靠边停车，以为警察是找别人的。突然警察出现在卡车两侧。
They opened my right door, my left door, and pulled their guns all over. So I cannot move. I can't even pull the key.
他们打开了我的右车门、左车门，用枪指着我。所以我动弹不得。我甚至无法拔出钥匙。
Wow.
哇。
So then he did the key for me, pulled the emergency brake. They take me out of the truck. I thought I was being kidnapped. I thought it was a mistake, you know? They identify themselves. They say, that's immigration, and you'll be going to Portugal next week. Never mind this country. Think about Portugal. Of course, I was in shock. I have my family, my kids sleeping over here 150 feet away. So I was not too happy.
然后他帮我拔了钥匙，拉起手刹。他们把我从卡车里拉出来。我以为我被绑架了。我以为是个误会，你知道吗？他们表明了身份。他们说，这是移民局，你下周就要去葡萄牙了。别管这个国家了。想想葡萄牙吧。当然，我惊呆了。我的家人，我的孩子们在 150 英尺外睡觉。所以我不太高兴。
It's still not clear why they came for him that particular day, what brought his case up on their radar. They put him in a van and drove him into Boston, right past his actual job site. He lays concrete on the massive tunnel highway construction project that's called the Big Dig.
目前还不清楚为什么他们在那一天特地来找他，是什么让他的案子引起了他们的注意。他们把他塞进一辆面包车，开车带他去波士顿，正好经过他实际的工作地点。他在那里铺设大型高速公路隧道建设项目，被称为“大挖掘”（Big Dig）。
I thought it was a bad dream, you know? I go by my job. I'm thinking, I'm supposed to be over there. I'm not supposed to be on all those [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我以为是一场噩梦，你知道吗？我经过我的工作地点。我在想，我应该在那儿的。我不应该在所有这些 [听不清] 上。
I was asleep when my next-door neighbor called and said, they took your husband.
我睡着的时候，隔壁邻居打电话说，他们把你丈夫带走了。
This is Maria Fredas, Mario's wife.
这是 Maria Fredas，Mario 的妻子。
And I knew in my heart that it was immigration, because we already had heard of a few cases. So when she said immigration, my first reaction was to run outside. Because I'm thinking he's still outside, but they already had taken him away. So the only thing I could do was, I got into the truck, and his coffee was still sitting there. The hot coffee and a warm bagel. And I took the truck and parked it into the yard and started calling family.
我心里知道是移民局，因为我们已经听说过一些案例了。所以当她说移民局时，我的第一反应是跑到外面。因为我以为他还在外面，但他们已经把他带走了。所以我唯一能做的就是，我进了卡车，他的咖啡还在那儿。热咖啡和一个温热的百吉饼。我把卡车开进院子，开始给家里人打电话。
I think the worst part was my daughter. She was, at the time, four. And that was hard for her, because she thought her dad had died. She said, "Why are these people here?" This was in the morning. "Why are you crying?" And I said, "Nothing." And she ran to the window and said, "Mommy, that's Daddy's truck. Did Daddy die?" I said, "No, Daddy didn't die." And she said, "Yes, he did." And I said, "No, he didn't," and she said, "Yeah, my Daddy died."
我觉得最难过的是我女儿。她当时四岁。那对她来说很难，因为她以为她爸爸死了。她说：“这些人为什么在这里？”这是在早上。“你为什么哭？”我说：“没什么。”她跑到窗边说：“妈妈，那是爸爸的卡车。爸爸死了吗？”我说：“不，爸爸没死。”她说：“是的，他死了。”我说：“不，他没死。”她说：“是啊，我爸爸死了。”
The INS held him for 20 days, and then his lawyer got him out on a technicality. A year later, he's still waiting for a final decision about whether he'll be sent to Portugal.
移民局关押了他 20 天，然后他的律师以技术性原因把他保了出来。一年后，他仍在等待关于他是否会被送往葡萄牙的最终决定。
As you've heard, the 1996 law did a few things. It made a lot of crimes deportable that weren't deportable before. It was retroactive, applying to crimes that happened years before it was written. And it did one more thing, and it's this third change that's probably had the most effect on this community and the country. It removed judges from the process.
如你所闻，1996 年的法律做了几件事。它使许多以前不需要遣返的罪行变成了可遣返罪行。它具有追溯力，适用于法律编写前几年的犯罪。它还做了另一件事，这第三项改变可能对这个社区和国家产生了最大的影响。它将法官剔除出了这个过程。
Before the 1996 law, Mario would have had the right to appear before a judge, who would examine the specifics of his case, take into account the fact that he hadn't had other arrests and that he's a parent of three children with a job and a house, and then decide whether he deserves to be deported. Fred Watt is an attorney in New Bedford who's handled dozens of these cases, including Mario's.
在 1996 年法律出台前，Mario 有权出现在法官面前，法官会审查他案件的具体细节，考虑到他没有其他逮捕记录，并且他是三个有工作和房产的孩子的父亲，然后决定他是否应该被遣返。Fred Watt 是新贝德福德的一名律师，他处理过几十起这类案件，包括 Mario 的案件。
I think that probably the easiest way to understand the changes in the law is to understand that what the new law or laws did is-- the big difference is that now the judges do not have the discretion, in many cases, to give a waiver from deportation.
我认为理解法律变化最简单的方法可能就是理解新法律所做的事情——最大的区别在于，现在在很多情况下，法官没有酌情权来给予遣返豁免。
Fred Watts says that if they had that discretion, well over half of his clients might have had a decent shot at staying in the US. Before the changes in the law, that's how many of his clients won their cases with judges. As it stands now, though, all sorts of cases lead to deportation more or less automatically.
Fred Watts 说，如果他们有酌情权，他的一半以上的客户可能都有很好的留在美国的希望。在法律修改之前，这就是他的许多客户在法官那里赢得案件的方式。然而，现在的状况是，各种各样的案件几乎都会自动导致遣返。
I never knew that this thing was going to happen like this, you know? Because I'm not a criminal. I consider myself-- I'm not a criminal. My problem was drink.
我从来没想到这种事情会这样发生，你知道吗？因为我不是罪犯。我认为自己——我不是罪犯。我的问题是喝酒。
Luis Ramos is 48, did construction and manufacturing work, and served a sentence for drunk driving. Before 1996, a judge might have taken away his driver's license and ruled that he posed no further danger to the community. Now the INS is planning to deport him.
Luis Ramos 48 岁，从事建筑和制造业工作，因酒驾服刑。在 1996 年之前，法官可能会吊销他的驾照，并裁定他不会再对社区构成威胁。现在移民局正计划遣返他。
I never go around robbing houses or something like that. I've worked in this country for 32 years. 32 years. And I never robbed nobody. I always pay taxes to the government. And I've hurt no one. I have an 18 years' marriage, two kids, wife. Never did nothing to hurt America.
我从来不去抢房子什么的。我在这个国家工作了 32 年。32 年。我从没抢过任何人。我总是向政府纳税。而且我没伤害任何人。我有 18 年的婚姻，两个孩子，妻子。从没做过伤害美国的事。
New Bedford and Fall River are both really pretty port towns, with cobblestones, colonial-looking downtowns, and small houses on streets winding back from the waterfront. And Portuguese immigrants have been coming here since the 1790s, because this was a major whaling town, and the Portuguese islands, the Azores, were full of whalers as well. A section of Moby Dick where Ishmael meets up with whalers from all over the world is set in New Bedford. This is the kind of place where it seems like every little store and doctor's office has a Portuguese name, and where many first-generation Portuguese immigrants never learned to speak English. Over half of the population is of Portuguese descent.
新贝德福德和福尔里弗都是非常漂亮的港口小镇，有鹅卵石街道、殖民风格的市中心，以及沿海滨蜿蜒后退的街道上的小房子。葡萄牙移民自 1790 年代以来就一直来到这里，因为这是一个主要的捕鲸镇，而葡萄牙群岛，亚速尔群岛，也满是捕鲸人。《白鲸记》中以实玛利遇到来自世界各地的捕鲸人的一段就发生在新贝德福德。这是一个似乎每家小店和医生办公室都有葡萄牙名字的地方，许多第一代葡萄牙移民从没学会说英语。超过一半的人口是葡萄牙后裔。
At this point, there have been so many deportations, a women's group has formed here, made up of mothers, sisters, and wives of men who've been deported to Portugal. They hold a monthly support group and weekly vigils in downtown New Bedford. They dress in black and carry signs protesting the deportations. Last month, they held a speaker's forum in a Fall River church, where women were invited to tell their stories, and politicians were invited to come and listen and respond.
目前，已经发生了太多的遣返事件，这里成立了一个妇女团体，由被遣返回葡萄牙的男人的母亲、姐妹和妻子组成。她们每月举行互助小组会议，每周在新贝德福德市中心举行守夜活动。她们身穿黑衣，举着抗议遣返的标语。上个月，她们在福尔里弗的一所教堂举行了演讲论坛，邀请妇女讲述她们的故事，并邀请政客前来倾听和回应。
I would also like to recognize Maria Costa, who's representing Congressman Jim McGovern.
我还想向代表 Jim McGovern 国会议员的 Maria Costa 致意。
About a dozen politicians showed up or sent their aides, most of them state and local representatives who can't do much about the federal immigration law. The women go up to the podium first-- a niece, a few sisters, a wife, several mothers-- and each one gets a few sentences into her story about someone's deportation and starts to cry.
大约有十几位政客出现或派出了助手，他们大多数是州和地方代表，对联邦移民法做不了什么。妇女们首先走到讲台前——一位侄女、几位姐妹、一位妻子、几位母亲——每位在讲到关于某人被遣返的故事几句后就开始哭泣。
Good afternoon, everybody. My name Mary [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I come today here to talk about my brother, Norbert Souza. He's in a jail for nine months. So I'm so confused in this life because--
大家下午好。我的名字叫 Mary [听不清]。我今天来到这里谈谈我的兄弟，Norbert Souza。他在监狱里待了九个月。所以我的人生非常困惑，因为——
--but this time it was different. In our car ride on the way to the airport, he told me, "Melanie, Titi's very sick."'
——但这次不同了。在我们去机场的车上，他告诉我，“Melanie，Titi 病得很重。”
My name is Lillian Rodericks. And I'm speaking on behalf of my husband.
我叫 Lillian Rodericks。我是代表我丈夫发言的。
Good evening. I'm here on behalf of my brother, Emmanual [? Meros. ?] He came to the US at the age of two and a half.
晚上好。我是代表我的兄弟 Emmanual Meros 来的。他在两岁半时来到美国。
This is the first political involvement of any kind that most of these women have ever had. As the number of deportees has grown and affected more and more families, even not very civic-minded people are becoming outraged. Guilherme Lourenco is a New Bedford fisherman, a sea scalloper. He was taken to Louisiana by the INS and detained for 15 months, after which his immigration case was decided in his favor, thanks to a lot of fancy footwork from his lawyer. He says his time away from home was especially hard on his two sons.
这是这些妇女大多数人第一次参与任何形式的政治活动。随着被遣返者人数的增加并影响了越来越多的家庭，即使是不太关心公民事务的人也开始感到愤怒。Guilherme Lourenco 是一名新贝德福德的渔民，捕扇贝的。他被移民局带到路易斯安那州并拘留了 15 个月，之后，多亏了他的律师的高超手段，他的移民案得到了有利于他的判决。他说他在外的时间对他两个儿子打击特别大。
They used to send me things that they'd drawn in school and stuff. And there was a lot of things that I notice about them, is they've changed, where they used to like-- you know, all kids used to like firemen, policemen. I'm going to be that when I grow up. And they had it different-- they would send me pictures of the cops getting killed. And I didn't really care too much for that. They lost some of the respect, I think, for authority. They knew I was being held for no crime, or a crime that I already had committed and paid for. So there was no reason for me being in jail. I think that's the way they looked at it.
他们以前会寄给我他们在学校画的东西之类的。我注意到关于他们有很多事情，就是他们变了，他们过去喜欢——你知道，所有孩子都喜欢消防员、警察。我长大后要成为那个。但他们不同了——他们会给我寄警察被杀的照片。我真的不太在意那个。我想他们对权威失去了一些尊重。他们知道我被关押是因为没有犯罪，或者是一个我已经犯过并付出了代价的罪行。所以我待在监狱里是没有理由的。我想他们是这么看的。
Lillian Rodericks is raising her three kids alone since her husband was deported a year ago. And they're not doing so well. While we're talking, Lillian's youngest child comes in, her eight-year-old son, Derek. He went with her to visit his father in Portugal the summer. She pulls his roller blades off for him.
Lillian Rodericks 自从她丈夫一年前被遣返后，就独自抚养三个孩子。他们的表现不太好。我们在谈话时，Lillian 最小的孩子进来了，她八岁的儿子 Derek。她今年夏天带他去葡萄牙看望父亲。她帮他脱掉轮滑鞋。
The three of them are not participating in school. I just had a meeting with the principal from his school. They told me, since we came back from seeing his father, he's had a major attitude. The principal said he's acting out on them. Because he's a child. He doesn't know how to put his feelings, so this is where he's bringing out his feelings, at the school. And that's what's happening with my other two. So when they changed this law, they didn't punish them, they punished the family, the children.
他们三个在学校都不参与活动。我刚和学校校长开了个会。他们告诉我，自从我们看完他父亲回来后，他的态度大变。校长说他在冲他们发火。因为他是个孩子。他不知道如何表达自己的感受，所以这就是他发泄感受的地方，在学校。这就是我另外两个孩子身上发生的情况。所以当他们修改这项法律时，他们惩罚的不是他们，而是这个家庭，这些孩子。
The '96 immigration law was passed in the wake of the Oklahoma City bombing and the World Trade Center bombing. Its sponsors hope to combat terrorists, and to stop what they thought were lenient immigration judges from allowing so many convicted felons to stay in the US. Immigration lawyer Fred Watt.
1996 年的移民法是在俄克拉荷马城爆炸案和世界贸易中心爆炸案之后通过的。其提案人希望打击恐怖分子，并阻止他们认为宽容的移民法官允许这么多已定罪的重罪犯留在美国。移民律师 Fred Watt。
I don't think that the average Republican or Democrat was aware of what this law was going to do. I'm not even sure the people who wrote it had a full understanding of it, because it took months for the immigration law community to understand it. I don't think that they necessarily meant it to affect the number of people it did. And I base that just because nobody seemed to get it, for the longest time. A good year. And the judges and the bar were all scratching their heads as the full impact of the law became clear.
我不认为普通共和党人或民主党人知道这项法律会产生什么影响。我甚至不确定起草它的人是否完全理解它，因为移民法界花了几个月的时间才理解它。我不认为他们一定想让它影响到这么多人。我之所以这么说，是因为很长一段时间没人明白它。整整一年。随着法律的全部影响变得清晰，法官和律师们都抓耳挠腮。
Here's one sign that Congress didn't intend for the law to work the way it has. There's a bill right now to soften some aspects of this law, backed by most of the original sponsors of the '96 law, and written by one of its key sponsors, Republican Bill McCollum of Florida. It passed the House and is awaiting a Senate vote right now. It would allow some people who have been deported retroactively to return. Fred Watts says it would help about a third of his clients. It won't affect any of the people we saw in the Bristol County jail, or Lillian Rodericks' husband, or Mario Fredas. It won't do the thing opponents of the '96 law want most-- put these deportation cases in front of judges again, as they were before 1996.
这是一个国会无意让法律如此运作的迹象。目前有一项法案旨在软化这项法律的某些方面，得到了 96 年法律大多数原始提案人的支持，并由其关键提案人之一，佛罗里达州的共和党人 Bill McCollum 起草。它已经在众议院通过，正在等待参议院投票。它将允许一些被追溯遣返的人返回。Fred Watts 说这会有助于他三分之一的客户。它不会影响我们在布里斯托县监狱看到的任何人，也不会影响 Lillian Rodericks 的丈夫或 Mario Fredas。它不会做 96 年法律反对者最想做的事——像 1996 年之前那样再次将这些遣返案件交给法官审理。
And I think that it's time that people thought about deportation for what it is. I mean, really, it's almost like a little death penalty case, every time you do one. And that's maybe a little bit melodramatic, but when you see the families, particularly the mothers, this is about the worst thing that can happen to a family.
而且我认为现在是人们思考遣返到底是什么的时候了。我的意思是，真的，每次你这样做，几乎就像一个小死刑案。这也许有点夸张，但当你看到这些家庭，特别是母亲们时，这是可能发生在一个家庭身上的最糟糕的事情。
I ask Mario Fredas, the guy who was nabbed with his bagel and coffee still sitting in his truck, for a tour of his house. After he and Maria had been married a couple of years, he bought this old two-story house that was completely run-down, condemned in fact, for a really cheap price.
我要求 Mario Fredas，那个被逮住时咖啡和百吉饼还留在卡车里的家伙，带我参观一下他的房子。在他和 Maria 结婚几年后，他以非常便宜的价格买下了这栋完全破败、实际上是被判为危房的两层旧房子。
This is a brand-new kitchen. It was an old one here. So I took it down. I did the floor tile. I take all the walls down. I put new electrical, plumbing, insulation.
这是一个全新的厨房。以前有一个旧的在这里。所以我把它拆了。我铺了地砖。我拆掉了所有的墙。我重新布了电线、管道、隔热材料。
The house is beautiful, on a quiet street with other houses that look like it. He's got plans to fix the basement. He says sometimes he relaxes in the backyard, daydreams about what he'll do with his life. And then he remembers all of a sudden how tenuous his future is, that he's still waiting for a final decision from INS.
这房子很漂亮，坐落在一条有着看起来相似房子的安静街道上。他有计划修缮地下室。他说有时他在后院放松，幻想着他将如何度过余生。然后他突然想起他的未来是多么脆弱，他还在这里等待移民局的最终决定。
I'm just thinking, maybe next week I get deported. Who knows? I'm just thinking, if they come get me tomorrow-- I don't know. Always my mind stops me, and says, you know, why am I trying to do this? Because I don't know what's going to happen to me. It's like, I'm out of balance, you know?
我只是在想，也许下周我就被遣返了。谁知道呢？我只是在想，如果他们明天来找我——我不知道。我的心总是阻止我，说，你知道，我为什么要努力做这些？因为我不知道我会发生什么。就像，我失去了平衡，你知道吗？
Mario shows me a panoramic photo of the island where he comes from in the Azores, lush green farmland in all directions. And he points to the spot where he'll move back to if he gets deported. He says it's a very small town with no industry other than farming. I ask him if he thinks of himself as an American, and he says no. He knows he's Portuguese. He says he's just built a life here, and had planned on living here forever, like a lot of other people do.
Mario 向我展示了一张他来自亚速尔群岛的岛屿的全景照片，四处都是郁郁葱葱的绿色农田。他指着如果他被遣返他将搬回的地点。他说这是一个非常小的城镇，除了农业没有任何工业。我问他是否认为自己是美国人，他说不。他知道他是葡萄牙人。他说他只是在这里建立了一个生活，并计划像许多其他人一样永远住在这里。
Blue Chevigny. Coming up, a US Congressman calls the Congress stupid. That's right, stupid. An INS official says that they're asked to enforce a law that's unfair. And other examples of your government at work, in a minute, from Public Radio International when our program continues.
Blue Chevigny。接下来，一位美国国会议员称国会是愚蠢的。没错，愚蠢。一位移民局官员说，他们被要求执行一项不公平的法律。以及你政府工作中的其他例子，稍后，在我们的节目继续时，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, an obscure law that you probably have not heard of that's deporting tens of thousands of people per year. We've arrived at Act Two of our show.
这里是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为你带来各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，是一个你可能没听说过的、每年遣返数万人的生僻法律。我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Whose Idea Was This Anyway? Thus far, on our program, we've been hearing about 1996 changes to the immigration law. That law, of course, is enforced by the Immigration and Naturalization Service, and at this point, the INS officially opposes certain parts of the '96 Immigration Act even while it uses them to kick people out of the country. Bill Strassberger is a spokesperson for the agency in Washington DC.
第二幕，这到底是谁的主意？到目前为止，在我们的节目中，我们一直在听关于 1996 年移民法修改的事情。当然，该法律由移民和归化局执行，目前，移民局正式反对 96 年移民法的某些部分，即使他们利用这些部分将人们踢出国家。Bill Strassberger 是该机构在华盛顿特区的发言人。
I think it's safe to say the INS feels that the law went a little too far, although we were pleased with a number of the things that were included in the law. It's harsh. It was overreaching in many ways. It was probably the best compromise that was available at the time.
我认为可以肯定地说，移民局认为这项法律走得有点太远了，尽管我们对法律中包含的一些内容感到满意。它很严酷。它在许多方面都越权了。这可能是当时能达到的最好的妥协。
In what ways did it go too far, in INS's view?
在移民局看来，它在哪些方面做得太过了？
The retroactivity of the law, reaching back, penalizing those who were convicted previously. I think the biggest problems, and what we really have advocated for the greatest change, is in the lack of discretion that we now have, that immigration judges now have. INS would like to see a return to that discretion, to allow immigration judges to review the totality of someone's life, not just the fact that they were convicted of a relatively minor offense 15 years ago, let's say.
法律的追溯力，回溯过去，惩罚那些之前被定罪的人。我认为最大的问题，以及我们真正主张进行最大改变的，是我们现在缺乏的酌情权，移民法官现在缺乏酌情权。移民局希望看到这种酌情权的回归，允许移民法官审查一个人生活的全部，而不仅仅是他在 15 年前被判犯有相对轻微的罪行这一事实。
It strikes me that INS is an odd situation, of having to enforce a law it doesn't agree with right now.
让我觉得移民局现在处于一个奇怪的境地，不得不执行一项它不同意的法律。
Well, that's quite often the case in law enforcement. The old phrase is, "I don't write the law. I just enforce them." And in many ways, that's true in this case. We give our input, but Congress does pass the law. The president signs the bill. And then we have to enforce it.
嗯，在执法中经常会出现这种情况。老话说是，“我不写法律。我只是执行它们。”在很多方面，这在案件中是真实的。我们提供我们的意见，但国会确实通过了法律。总统签署了法案。然后我们必须执行它。
Bill Strassberger of the INS. Meanwhile, legislators are hard at work backpedaling on the law. As you've heard, one of the original sponsors of the '96 act, Congressman Bill McCollum of Florida, has drafted a new bill that undoes some of the more controversial parts of his '96 law. The House of Representatives has approved the measure. It's still awaiting a vote by the Senate.
移民局的 Bill Strassberger。同时，立法者们正在忙于撤回这项法律。如你所闻，96 年法案的原始提案人之一，佛罗里达州的国会议员 Bill McCollum，起草了一项新法案，撤销他 96 年法律中一些最具争议的部分。众议院已经批准了这项措施。它仍在等待参议院投票。
But as it waits, the question is, why did they pass the '96 law in the first place, this law that they now want to fix? What were they hoping to accomplish?
但在等待的同时，问题是，他们为什么要首先通过 96 年的法律，这项他们现在想要修复的法律？他们希望达成什么目标？
It's a case of an outrageous law substantively being made in an outrageous way procedurally.
这是一个在程序上以令人愤慨的方式制造出的实质上令人愤慨的法律的案例。
This is Congressman Barney Frank. All of those Portuguese people from Fall River and New Bedford that we heard earlier in the program-- they're his constituents. They live in his district. And so he supports this new McCollum bill which reverses part of the '96 law. Back in 1996, he was on the House committee that handled the immigration bill, and he says that to understand how the most controversial parts of the bill became law, consider just one of the most contentious pieces of all this, retroactivity. He says the committee considered a proposal that would make tougher immigration standards retroactive.
这是国会议员 Barney Frank。我们在节目中早些时候听到的那些来自福尔里弗和新贝德福德的葡萄牙人——他们是他的选民。他们住在他的选区。所以他支持这项新的 McCollum 法案，该法案推翻了 96 年法律的一部分。早在 1996 年，他在处理移民法案的众议院委员会，他说要理解最争议的部分是如何成为法律的，考虑一下这里所有争议中最有争议的部分之一，追溯力。他说委员会考虑了一项提议，将更严厉的移民标准追溯应用。
Now, when they offered that in the committee, we were able to defeat them. The Republicans win most things around here, but this was so bad that almost all the Democrats and a couple of Republicans rebelled.
现在，当他们在委员会中提出这一点时，我们能够击败他们。共和党人在这个地方赢得了大多数东西，但这太糟糕了，以至于几乎所有的民主党人和几个共和党人都反抗了。
The bill, without retroactivity, went forward. The House and Senate approved it. And then comes the procedure that Barney Frank was just calling outrageous. A conference committee met. That's a committee with both members of the House and the Senate. Well, they didn't exactly meet in the normal way.
这项没有追溯力的法案继续推进。众议院和参议院批准了它。然后出现了 Barney Frank 刚才称为令人愤慨的程序。一个会议委员会会面了。那是一个既有众议院成员又有参议院成员的委员会。嗯，他们并没有完全以正常的方式会面。
The final bill was written by the Republicans in a conference committee which never met. Literally, the Democrats were excluded. The Republican leaderships of the two committees wrote the bill. They put in that provision that had been defeated by vote of committee, the provision that said, you will retroactively be deportable automatically for certain crimes that had not previously carried that penalty. And then they put it into the omnibus appropriation bill of that year.
最终的法案是由共和党人在一个从未会面的会议委员会中写成的。从字面上讲，民主党人被排除了。两个委员会的共和党领导人写了这份法案。他们加入了那个在委员会投票中被击败的条款，那个条款说，对于某些以前没有携带该惩罚的罪行，你将被自动追溯遣返。然后他们把它放进了那一年的综合拨款法案中。
This is the bill that funds all of government activities?
这是资助所有政府活动的法案？
Exactly. Or most of them. Now, the immigration bill had been voted on, in the House at least, and maybe in the Senate, separately. But at that time, these obnoxious provisions about retroactivity weren't in it. They were added by the Republican congressional leadership in a last-minute secret meeting and incorporated into the overall bill so there was never any chance to vote on them.
确切地说。或者大多数。现在，移民法案已经在众议院至少投了票，也许在参议院也是，分别投的票。但在那时，这些关于追溯力的讨厌条款并不在其中。它们是被共和党国会领导层在最后一刻的秘密会议上添加进去的，并被纳入了整体法案中，所以从来没有任何投票的机会。
Were you following this closely enough yourself that you actually were aware that this thing had been put back in?
你自己跟进得足够紧吗，以至于你实际上知道这东西被放回去了？
Oh, yes. Yes, because I was a member of the House/Senate conference committee that never met. And we insisted, finally, the Democrats, on a meeting. But at the meeting, no motions were allowed. The rules of the House and the Senate allowed them to do this. And they explained that they were doing this. We complained about it and we objected very strenuously, but the problem was that, in the first place, other parts of the immigration bill seem attractive to people. But even worse, there was never any separate vote on this. It was just part of the one overall package.
哦，是的。是的，因为我是那个从未会面的众议院/参议院会议委员会的成员。我们最终，民主党人，坚持要开会。但在会议上，不允许任何动议。众议院和参议院的规则允许他们这样做。他们解释说他们正在这样做。我们对此进行了抱怨，我们非常强烈地反对，但问题是，首先，移民法案的其他部分对人们来说似乎很有吸引力。但更糟糕的是，从来没有任何单独的投票。它只是整体方案的一部分。
Now when this passed in '96, did legislators understand what they were passing?
现在当它在 96 年通过时，立法者们明白他们在通过什么吗？
Most did not, unfortunately. Most members did not know that the ultimate bill they were voting for included this obnoxious provision. But the Republican leadership manipulated the procedures so that they were able to do it anyway.
不幸的是，大多数不知道。大多数成员不知道他们投票支持的最终法案包括这个讨厌的条款。但共和党领导层操纵了程序，使得他们无论如何都能做到。
So you have this new bill which is now working its way through the legislative process.
所以你有了这项新法案，现在正在通过立法程序。
It's past the House, correct.
它通过了众议院，没错。
What would it change?
它会改变什么？
It undoes most of the bad effects but not all of the retroactivity. And it also says, very importantly, at my insistence, if you have already been deported because of this, and you can show that you would not have been deported had the law not been so changed, you can come home. So the nice thing is that we're doing away with retroactivity retroactively. Common sense will come back into the process.
它撤销了大多数坏的影响，但没有撤销所有的追溯力。而且它还说，非常重要的是，在我的坚持下，如果你因为这个已经被遣返了，并且你能证明如果法律没有这样修改你就不会被遣返，你可以回家。所以好消息是我们正在追溯地取消追溯力。常识将回归到这个过程中。
My understanding, though, is that what's going through in this current legislation is that it doesn't give judges discretion again for these cases since '96.
然而，我的理解是，当前立法中通过的内容并没有让法官在 96 年后的这些案件中再次拥有酌情权。
Right. Since '96 it does not. As I said, it only repeals the retroactivity.
没错。自 96 年以来没有。如我所说，它只废除了追溯力。
Why doesn't Congress just let the immigration judges look at the cases--
为什么国会不让移民法官再次审理这些案件——
Well, why don't you ask the people who are doing that? I thought it was stupid and cruel then. I still think it is. And I oppose it. I can't tell you. I really am not a good explainer of other people's bad mistakes and evil intentions. I have enough trouble with my own.
嗯，你为什么不问那些正在做这件事的人呢？我当时就觉得它愚蠢而残忍。我现在仍然觉得是。我反对它。我不能告诉你。我真的不擅长解释别人的错误和邪恶意图。我处理自己的问题就够麻烦的了。
Congressman Barney Frank. We invited the key Republican legislators behind the '96 law to come onto our program and explain why they thought it was necessary in the first place. All four-- Congressman Lamar Smith of Texas, Bill McCollum of Florida, Henry Hyde of Illinois, and Senator Spence Abraham of Michigan-- all declined our interview requests, saying they were too busy with the end of the legislative session and the fall elections. So to understand better why we as a nation might want these controversial parts of the law, we turn to an organization called FAIR, the Federation for American Immigration Reform, which strongly supported the '96 law and still stands by it.
国会议员 Barney Frank。我们邀请了 96 年法律背后的关键共和党立法者来到我们的节目，解释他们为什么认为首先有必要。所有四位——德克萨斯州的国会议员 Lamar Smith，佛罗里达州的 Bill McCollum，伊利诺伊州的 Henry Hyde，以及密歇根州的参议员 Spence Abraham——都拒绝了我们的采访请求，称他们忙于立法会议结束和秋季选举。所以为了更好地理解为什么我们作为一个国家可能想要这些法律中争议的部分，我们转向了一个名为 FAIR 的组织，即美国移民改革联合会，它强烈支持 96 年的法律，并且仍然坚持它。
We're talking about immigrants to this country who have not become US citizens, who are simply living here under our laws as, in effect, guests either invited or uninvited.
我们谈论的是来到这个国家但尚未成为美国公民的移民，他们仅仅根据我们的法律作为客人生活在这里，无论是受邀还是未受邀。
This is Jack Martin, director for special projects at FAIR.
这是 Jack Martin，FAIR 的特别项目主任。
We certainly have felt that it is fair that an active effort was undertaken for removing people who have abused the hospitality of our society.
我们当然感到，采取积极努力驱逐那些滥用我们社会好客的人是公平的。
Let's talk about retroactivity a little bit. One of our producers met a man named Mario Fredas who was convicted of drug charges, served three years, got out in 1991. He was a green card holder. He cleaned up, has a family and kids now, works on the Big Dig in Boston. Didn't he already pay for his crime? What good does it do to deport him?
让我们谈谈追溯力。我们的一位制作人遇到了一名叫 Mario Fredas 的男子，他因毒品指控被定罪，服刑三年，1991 年出来。他持有绿卡。他改过自新，现在有了家庭和孩子，在波士顿的大挖掘工程工作。他不是已经为他的罪行付出了代价吗？遣返他有什么好处？
There are many cases that have received publicity of people such as the one that you're referring to, who have committed what may seem a fairly minor offense. And even though they have paid a debt to society, under the law, if they had just come into the country after the '96 act, they would be deportable at the time that they had paid their service. In other words, we have judged that these people have abused their immigrant status and should be removed back to the country that they came from.
有很多案件得到了媒体关注，比如你提到的那个人，他犯下了一项可能看起来相当轻微的罪行。即使他们已经向社会偿还了债务，根据法律，如果他们在 96 年法案之后刚来到这个国家，他们将在服刑期满时被遣返。换句话说，我们判断这些人滥用了他们的移民身份，应该被遣返回他们来自的国家。
And I think that you can make a reasonable case for people in certain limited circumstances where they've demonstrated that they are responsible members of the society to continue to stay in this country. But the Attorney General's discretionary power, under the law, is amply sufficient for taking care of these exceptional cases.
而且我认为在某些有限的情况下，当人们证明他们是社会负责任的成员时，你可以提出一个合理的理由让他们继续留在美国。但在法律下，司法部长的酌情权对于处理这些特殊案件是绰绰有余的。
In other words, the Attorney General can overturn these cases and basically say, these people shouldn't be deported. It's not fair.
换句话说，司法部长可以推翻这些案件，基本上说，这些人不应该被遣返。这不公平。
That's correct.
那是正确的。
Why not just have judicial review? Why not just have immigration judges look at the cases, the way it was before? If somebody's going to have to weigh the merits of each case.
为什么不进行司法审查呢？为什么不让移民法官像以前那样审理案件呢？如果有人必须权衡每个案件的优点。
Well, the main reason for that is because that lends itself to judicial shopping, which was a standard practice and one of the main abuses that the '96 act was intending to correct. A lot of immigration lawyers were in effect given free rein to shop around from judge to judge during a very lengthy and extensive appeal process that ended only when they were able to find the judge, finally, who would agree to forgive the offense and allow that person to stay in the country.
嗯，主要原因是因为这导致了司法购物，这是 96 年法案旨在纠正的标准做法和主要弊端之一。很多移民律师实际上被给予了自由，在漫长而广泛的上诉过程中从一个法官转向另一个法官，直到他们最终能够找到那个愿意宽恕罪行并允许那个人留在国家的法官。
Jack Martin of the Federation for American Immigration Reform. He's exactly right, by the way, that the Attorney General has the power under current law to stop deportation of anybody who she thinks is deserving. Janet Reno could issue an order allowing Mario Fredas, or any other potential deportees, to stay in the US. In fact, the INS itself has the power to look the other way in any case and not deport somebody. But it's almost never done.
美国移民改革联合会的 Jack Martin。顺便说一下，他说得完全正确，司法部长在现行法律下有权阻止她认为值得的任何人的遣返。Janet Reno 可以发布一项命令，允许 Mario Fredas 或任何其他潜在被遣返者留在美国。事实上，移民局本身有权对任何案件视而不见，不遣返某人。但这几乎从未做过。
Presumably this is why. If Janet Reno or the INS pardon somebody who then went on to commit terrible crimes, the Attorney General and her party and its candidates-- they are the ones who would take the blame. Now, the Republicans say that is just fine. If something bad happens, politicians should take the heat for it. And Republican congressmen like Lamar Smith have been saying for years now that INS does not need a new law. It should just make exceptions for those cases that merit it. I asked Barney Frank what he thought about his colleague saying that.
大概这就是原因。如果 Janet Reno 或移民局赦免了某人，而那个人随后去犯下了可怕的罪行，司法部长和她的政党及其候选人——他们就是会被责备的人。现在，共和党人说这很好。如果发生了坏事，政客就应该承担责任。像 Lamar Smith 这样的共和党国会议员多年来一直说，移民局不需要新法律。它应该只对那些值得的案件做出例外处理。我问 Barney Frank 对他的同事说的话有什么想法。
Oh, that's an outrageous cover-up of themselves. If you go back to the debates in '96, their argument was precisely that they had to take away the discretion from the INS. Then, when that law began to have outrageous results, they said, "Well, it's not our fault. The INS should have used its discretion." But the very purpose of the law was to take away the discretion.
哦，那简直是对他们自己的无耻掩盖。如果你回到 96 年的辩论中，他们的论点正是他们必须剥夺移民局的酌情权。然后，当那项法律开始产生令人愤慨的结果时，他们说，“嗯，这不是我们的错。移民局应该使用它的酌情权。”但法律的初衷恰恰是剥夺酌情权。
You know what their argument is? Well, the INS in effect should ignore the law selectively. Even though the law says these people should automatically be deported, the INS should simply refuse to invoke it in these cases. Now, I think that's probably true in a lot of these cases, but don't pass a law and then blame the INS for carrying out the law that you passed, and say, well, it's their fault, they should have ignored me.
你知道他们的论点是什么吗？嗯，移民局实际上应该有选择性地忽视法律。即使法律规定这些人应该被自动遣返，移民局也应该简单地拒绝在这些案件中援引它。现在，我认为这在很多这些案件中可能是真的，但不要通过一项法律，然后又因为执行你通过的法律而责怪移民局，并说，嗯，这是他们的错，他们应该忽视我。
One last political note with all this. We contacted the two presidential campaigns to find out where they stand on the '96 immigration law. Of course, in the scheme of presidential politics, this is not a very big issue. And, in fact, the Bush campaign does not have an official position on the law. The Gore campaign does, though. Candidate Gore believes that the '96 law went too far, and favors putting these cases back in the hands of judges.
关于所有这些，最后的一点政治笔记。我们联系了两位总统竞选团队，以找出他们对 96 年移民法的立场。当然，在总统政治的蓝图中，这不是一个很大的问题。事实上，布什的竞选团队对该法律没有官方立场。不过，戈尔的竞选团队有。候选人戈尔认为 96 年的法律走得太远了，并赞成将这些案件交回法官手中。
[MUSIC -- "I'M JUST A BILL" BY SCHOOLHOUSE ROCK]
[音乐——Schoolhouse Rock 的“我只是一个法案”]
Act Three, Man Without a Country. This next story is about another little-known part of US immigration policy. What happens if the INS wants to deport you but there is nowhere to deport you to? People awaiting deportation, by the way, are housed in county jails around the country. And they can be there for a long, long time. Alex Kotlowitz has this story about the unusual relationships that sometimes form between these deportees and their jailers.
第三幕，没有国家的男人。下一个故事是关于美国移民政策的另一个鲜为人知的部分。如果移民局想要遣返你，但没有地方可以遣返你，会发生什么？顺便说一句，等待遣返的人被安置在全国各地的县监狱中。他们可能会在那里待上很长、很长时间。Alex Kotlowitz 有这个关于这些被遣返者和他们的狱卒之间有时形成的非同寻常关系的故事。
On a recent Friday night in Victoria, Texas, a blue-collar town of 60,000, I met up with Trung Tran. Trung is a Vietnamese immigrant and had driven the two hours from Houston where he works as a lab technician at a sleep disorder clinic. He's 33, broad-shouldered, handsome, and well-dressed in a sapphire blue shirt, khaki pants, and Tommy Hilfiger boots. Together we drove to the home of Virginia [? Escahito ?] and her husband, Lupe. Virginia had met Trung when she was a guard at the local jail and Trung was an inmate. Virginia, who is 45, is a short roundish woman with red hair and rosy cheeks. She feels somewhat maternal towards Trung, and when we arrived, she embraced him.
在德克萨斯州维多利亚的一个最近的周五晚上，一个 6 万人口的蓝领小镇，我见到了 Trung Tran。Trung 是一名越南移民，从休斯顿开车两个小时赶来，他在那里的一家睡眠障碍诊所担任实验室技术员。他 33 岁，肩膀宽阔，英俊，穿着深蓝色衬衫、卡其色裤子和 Tommy Hilfiger 靴子，打扮得体。我们一起开车前往 Virginia Escahito 和她丈夫 Lupe 的家。Virginia 在当地监狱当守卫时认识了 Trung，当时 Trung 是囚犯。45 岁的 Virginia 是一个矮胖的红发女人，脸颊红润。她对 Trung 有些母性，当我们到达时，她拥抱了他。
?] Hi, Tran. How are you doing, Tran?
你好，Tran。你好吗，Tran？
Pretty good.
很好。
Virginia pulled on Trung's thick black hair.
Virginia 拽了拽 Trung 浓密的黑发。
?] I always look at Trung's hair--
我总是看 Trung 的头发——
It's grayer.
它更灰了。
?] --to see if it's any grayer. Because it was jet black in the jail went I met him. And he was so, so skinny, and I was kind of worried for him for a while. And now his cheeks are chunky, and he's got a little gray hair. Every time I see him, I see more. But he looks good. I'm glad to see him.
——看看它有没有更灰。因为当我认识他时，他在监狱里时它是乌黑的。他当时非常非常瘦，我担心了他好一阵子。现在他的脸颊胖嘟嘟的，他有一些灰头发了。每次见到他，我都看到更多。但他看起来不错。见到他我很高兴。
This is the story of an unlikely friendship, friendship between captor and captured, a connection that pushed both an American and an immigrant to question their place in America. This tale begins in 1975, when Trung and his family fled Vietnam for America. Trung was seven at the time. His mother had worked for the US military. The Trans eventually settled in Houston, where Trung's parents bought and ran a convenience store.
这是一个不太可能的友谊的故事，俘虏者与被俘虏者之间的友谊，一种促使美国人和移民都质疑他们在美国家地位的联系。这个故事始于 1975 年，当时 Trung 和他的家人逃离越南前往美国。Trung 当时七岁。他的母亲曾为美军工作。Tran 一家最终定居休斯顿，Trung 的父母在那里购买并经营一家便利店。
Trung quickly adapted to his new country. In high school he ran track. On weekends, he attended Friday night football games and afterwards joined classmates at Kentucky Fried Chicken. His date for the prom was the homecoming queen. Those he hung out with, he says, were all Americans. He had no Vietnamese friends.
Trung 很快适应了他的新国家。在高中，他参加田径运动。周末，他参加周五晚上的足球比赛，之后和同学一起去肯德基。他的舞会舞伴是返校节女王。他说，他交往的那些人都是美国人。他没有越南朋友。
I just lived since then like a typical American kid, grew up and played sports and went to school and did the whole nine yards. And I went through the procedure of even trying to apply for citizenship with my whole family. And I went through, took the test and everything. And the whole time, I graduated from high school, went and filled out my draft card, did the whole thing. And already, I filled out my financial aid paper and anything else-- I'd put down as a US citizen.
从那时起，我就像一个典型的美国孩子一样生活，长大、参加运动、上学，做了所有的一切。我甚至经历了试图为全家人申请公民身份的过程。我经历了，参加了考试之类的。整个过程中，我高中毕业，去填写了我的征兵卡，完成了整件事。而且我已经填好了我的经济援助文件和其他任何东西——我都填为美国公民。
Trung went on to college at Texas Southern University, and there he lost his footing. His grades slipped and his scholarship was rescinded. He began to sell crack cocaine, and he was pretty good at it, netting $500 to a $1,000 a week. On October 19, 1992, he was arrested and charged with drug trafficking and money laundering. He plead guilty to both counts and served 32 months in federal prison. But when his time was up, he wasn't released. Trung, in fact, was not a citizen, though he was a lawful permanent resident. While he had begun the application process, he never completed it. Given the serious nature of Trung's crime and the fact that he was not a citizen, an immigration judge could and did decide to deport him.
Trung 继续在德克萨斯南方大学上大学，在那里他失去了平衡。他的成绩下滑，奖学金被撤销。他开始销售快克可卡因，而且他很擅长，每周净赚 500 到 1000 美元。1992 年 10 月 19 日，他被捕并被控贩毒和洗钱。他对两项指控均认罪，并在联邦监狱服刑 32 个月。但当他刑期满时，他没有被释放。事实上，Trung 不是公民，尽管他是合法的永久居民。虽然他开始了申请程序，但他从未完成它。鉴于 Trung 犯罪的严重性质以及他不是公民的事实，移民法官可以并且确实决定遣返他。
But there was a catch. Vietnam is one of a number of countries, including Cuba, Cambodia, and Laos, which won't accept deported individuals. And so Trung was without a homeland. Vietnam didn't want him, nor did the US. So what to do? The INS's policy has been to keep people like Trung incarcerated, even though they've completed their criminal sentences. The INS sent Trung to the county jail in New Braunfels, Texas.
但有一个陷阱。越南是包括古巴、柬埔寨和老挝在内的若干不接受被遣返个人的国家之一。所以 Trung 没有祖国。越南不想要他，美国也不想要他。那该怎么办？移民局的政策是继续监禁像 Trung 这样的人，尽管他们已经完成了刑事判决。移民局把 Trung 送到了德克萨斯州新布朗费尔斯的县监狱。
To tell you the truth, at first when I was in INS detention, it was like a cat and mouse game between the officers and the inmates. And they had a lot of officers that were veterans, because they went to the military and so forth. So they would make comments, calling me [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] VC, stuff like that. When they served us our meal time-- "Here, you little VC, get your food."
老实说，起初当我在移民局拘留所时，这就像警察和囚犯之间的猫鼠游戏。他们有很多退伍军官，因为他们去过军队之类的。所以他们会发表评论，称我为 [听不清] 越共，之类的话。当他们送餐时——“嘿，你这个小越共，吃你的饭。”
Then, in May of 1997, Trung was transferred to the county jail in Victoria. Trung had no reason to expect he'd be treated any different there. The building itself is an imposing two-story cinder block structure, and like most county jails was built to hold inmates for only short stretches, anywhere from a few hours to a few months, while they awaited their trial or their sentencing. The jail doesn't allow television. The only outdoor facilities are two courtyards, each the size of a basketball court. Inmates are allowed outside for a total of three hours a week. Inmates have no privacy. There are no cells, just dormitory-style locked rooms which house anywhere from 4 to 24 prisoners in bunk beds.
然后，1997 年 5 月，Trung 被转移到维多利亚的县监狱。Trung 没有理由期待他在那里会受到不同的对待。建筑本身是一个令人印象深刻的两层煤渣砖结构，像大多数县监狱一样，它是为关押囚犯短时间而建的，从几个小时到几个月不等，等待审判或判决。监狱不允许电视。唯一的户外设施是两个庭院，每个都有篮球场大小。囚犯每周总共被允许在户外待三个小时。囚犯没有隐私。没有牢房，只有宿舍式的锁闭房间，每个房间住着 4 到 24 名囚犯，睡在双层床上。
It's jail facilities like this, designed for locking people up temporarily, to which the INS sends those like Trung whom it's detaining for indefinite periods. There are roughly 4,000 such detainees, which publicly the INS refers to as long-termers, and which internally the agency has called lifers, a suggestion that this could be their permanent home.
正是像这样的监狱设施，设计用于临时关押人们，移民局把像 Trung 这样的人送到了这里，因为它正在无限期扣留他们。大约有 4000 名这样的被拘留者，移民局公开称他们为长期服刑者，在内部该机构称他们为无期徒刑者，暗示这可能是他们永久的家。
At Victoria, Trung shared a cell with Julio Martul. Julio, who was a legal permanent resident as well, emigrated from Cuba, committed a crime, served his six months, and was then ordered deported. But Cuba won't take him back, so he was placed in the Victoria county jail indefinitely.
在维多利亚，Trung 和 Julio Martul 住在一个牢房。Julio 也是合法的永久居民，从古巴移民，犯了罪，服了六个月刑，然后被命令遣返。但古巴不会接受他回去，所以他被无限期地安置在维多利亚县监狱。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[葡萄牙语演讲]
There are some people who were sentenced here to two years. Then they let them out. They've come back here, committed another crime. They served their time, they let them out, and now they're back a third time. And they'll come back here and they ask me, "When are you going to get out?" And they don't believe it.
有些人在这里被判了两年。然后他们让他们出去了。他们回来了，又犯了另一项罪。他们服刑期满，他们让他们出去，现在他们是第三次回来。他们会回到这里，问我，“你什么时候出去？”他们不相信。
It's at the Victoria county jail where Trung met Virginia. Virginia was a jail guard responsible for the institution's educational program. Many of the detainees attended language classes, and they would tell her of their situation. "How could someone be in jail and not know when they were getting out?" She would ask of them. She was puzzled.
正是维多利亚县监狱，Trung 遇见了 Virginia。Virginia 是一名监狱守卫，负责该机构的教育计划。许多被拘留者参加语言课程，他们会告诉她他们的处境。“一个人怎么能在监狱里却不知道什么时候出去？”她会问他们。她感到困惑。
?] Because they had no date, no release date. There was no release date for them. And I'm going, everybody's got a release date here. Except INS. And it was just unreal. I couldn't comprehend that. I'd come home and tell my husband, I'm in the wrong job. I'm just in the wrong job, because it was just so frustrating sometimes. And I felt like I couldn't do enough for these people. I couldn't do enough.
因为他们没有日期，没有释放日期。对他们来说没有释放日期。我心想，这里的每个人都有释放日期。除了移民局。这真是太离谱了。我无法理解。我会回家告诉我的丈夫，我找错工作了。我只是找错工作了，因为有时候太令人沮丧了。我觉得我为这些人做得不够。我做得不够。
She began to call the INS to try to get some answers for Julio, Trung, and the others. I think, though, she was also trying to make sense of it herself.
她开始致电移民局试图为 Julio、Trung 和其他人寻找答案。我想，虽然，她也试图让自己理解它。
?] I would ask, what was their status? They wanted to know, and we wanted to know also.
我会问，他们的状态是什么？他们想知道，我们也想知道。
And they would just tell you that they couldn't tell you anything.
他们只会告诉你他们什么都不能告诉你。
?] Right. That they could not tell me anything.
没错。他们什么都不能告诉我。
That must have driven you batty.
那一定让你疯了。
?] Well, I felt bad. Because what was I going to tell these guys? There they were, standing by me or sitting at the desk and waiting for an answer. And they were so happy that I was making a call for them. And then for me to tell them, well, they wouldn't even talk to me, you know?
嗯，我感到难过。因为我要告诉这些家伙什么？他们就站在我旁边或坐在桌子旁等待答案。他们很高兴我在为他们打电话。然后我告诉他们，嗯，他们甚至不跟我谈话，你知道吗？
Other guards at Victoria, many of whom like Virginia are first- or second-generation Americans, were equally perplexed. And so they too found ways to make life just a bit more bearable for these INS detainees. The guards gave the lifers certain privileges and did so at some risk. A sergeant at a nearby jail was fired after she publicly questioned the policy of detaining immigrants indefinitely. The guards at Victoria made many of them trustees, which allowed them some freedom of movement in the jail. They were assigned to kitchen duties or to mopping floors, or in the case of Trung, to the GED program. Virginia looked out for Trung and the others.
维多利亚的其他守卫，他们中许多像 Virginia 一样是第一代或第二代美国人，同样感到困惑。所以他们也找到了让这些移民局被拘留者的生活变得稍微好受一点的方法。守卫们给了无期徒刑者某些特权，这样做承担了一些风险。附近一所监狱的一名中士在公开质疑无限期拘留移民的政策后被解雇。维多利亚的守卫使他们中的许多人成为受托人，这让他们在监狱里获得了一些行动自由。他们被分配到厨房工作或拖地，或者像 Trung 的情况，被分配到 GED 计划。Virginia 照顾 Trung 和其他人。
?] Some of these inmates have not seen their families in so many years. And they would ask me, "Miss Virginia, my family hasn't seen me in so long. They don't even know how-- do you think you could take a picture of me?" And maybe I shouldn't have, but I did. I took pictures of these guys and sent them home. And I think somebody had warned me, "Virginia, you know you might get in trouble by doing that to these inmates, because they're incarcerated." And I'd go, "Yeah, but they've already done their time."
一些囚犯已经很多年没见过家人了。他们会问我，“Virginia 小姐，我的家人已经很久没见到我了。他们甚至不知道怎么——你认为你能给我拍张照吗？”也许我不应该这样做，但我做了。我给这些人拍了照片并寄回了家。我想有人警告过我，“Virginia，你知道你可能会因为给这些囚犯这样做而惹上麻烦，因为他们被监禁了。”我说，“是的，但他们已经服完了刑。”
They were small favors, but they showed a level of trust that doesn't ordinarily exist between guard and prisoner. Some deputies would bring back an extra hamburger or sandwich from lunch to give to the men. Teachers at the jail gave the lifers email accounts so they could communicate with their attorneys, and allowed them access to the internet so they could keep up with the changes in the immigration law. Trung, in fact, found an internet site in Spanish for Julio.
这些是小恩小惠，但它们显示出了一种通常不存在于守卫和囚犯之间的信任。一些副警长会从午餐中带回一个额外的汉堡或三明治给这些人。监狱的老师给了无期徒刑者电子邮件账户，这样他们就可以与他们的律师交流，并允许他们访问互联网，这样他们就可以跟上移民法的变化。事实上，Trung 为 Julio 找到了一个西班牙语的互联网网站。
One detainee, Victor [? Altume, ?] who'd served 16 years for kidnapping and aggravated battery, charges stemming from a bar fight, became the chef at the jail. The deputy sheriffs were such fans of Victor's cooking that they'd bring Victor along to their Monday night softball games, where he'd grill for them their favorites-- fajitas, tacos, and hot dogs. Victor was so well-liked that when he went to a local hospital for emergency heart surgery, so many deputy sheriffs visited him the hospital staff thought he too was in law enforcement.
一名被拘留者，Victor Altume，因绑架和严重伤害罪服刑 16 年，这些指控源于一次酒吧斗殴，成为了监狱的厨师。副警长们是 Victor 烹饪的粉丝，他们会带上 Victor 参加他们的周一晚上的垒球比赛，在那里他会为他们烧烤他们最喜欢的食物——法希塔、炸玉米饼和热狗。Victor 很受欢迎，以至于当他去当地医院接受紧急心脏手术时，这么多副警长去探望他，以至于医院工作人员以为他也是执法人员。
A jail officer allowed Trung and five other lifers, including Julio, to room together. And the guards found ways to get the INS detainees outside for more than their allotted three hours a week.
一名监狱官员允许 Trung 和其他五名无期徒刑者，包括 Julio，住在一起。守卫们找到了让移民局被拘留者每周在户外待的时间超过分配的三个小时的方法。
?] Well, one time we went out and painted that mural.
嗯，有一次我们出去画了那幅壁画。
And I was shocked when Miss Virginia said, well, you know your going out with us today, and we got approved from the INS. And please don't run on me.
当我听到 Virginia 小姐说，嗯，你知道你今天和我们一起出去，而且我们得到了移民局的批准时，我惊呆了。请不要跑掉。
?] And I was so scared when I first took Tran. I was going, "Tran, please don't run on me, Tran. Because I can't run that fast. And I'm not going to run after you." And it's going to be my job, because they told me, "If he runs, it'll be your job."
我第一次带 Tran 时太害怕了。我心想，“Tran，请不要跑掉，Tran。因为我跑不了那么快。而且我不会追你。”这将是我的工作，因为他们告诉我，“如果他跑了，这将是你的工作。”
For Trung and the others, there was a clear incentive to win over the guards. About a year and a half ago, under pressure from immigrants' rights groups, the INS began reviewing the cases of lifers. If the agency determined that the detainee was not a danger to society or a flight risk, they considered releasing them, and the only way Trung or the others could show that was by recommendations from those who knew them best, their captors.
对于 Trung 和其他人来说，赢得守卫的好感有明确的动力。大约一年半前，在移民权利团体的压力下，移民局开始审查无期徒刑者的案件。如果该机构确定被拘留者不对社会构成危险或有潜逃风险，他们就会考虑释放他们，而 Trung 或其他人证明这一点的唯一方法就是那些最了解他们的人，即他们的俘虏者的推荐。
And indeed, the jail guards wrote letters to the INS, urging them to release these men. One sergeant wrote on behalf of Victor, the cook, "When Victor leaves this jail, he will be missed by the employees. Many of us depend on him. The only complaint I might have of Victor is he's a little heavy on the garlic." A dozen other guards and jail staff wrote on behalf of other detainees, including Julio and Trung. And after two and a half years in indefinite detention, Victor, who's now 53, was released, and someone at the jail helped him get a job as chef at a small local seafood restaurant. Victor still volunteers his culinary skills at the guards' Monday night softball games.
事实上，监狱守卫写信给移民局，敦促他们释放这些人。一名中士代表厨师 Victor 写道：“当 Victor 离开这个监狱时，员工们会想念他。我们许多人都依赖他。我对 Victor 的唯一抱怨可能是他的大蒜味有点重。”其他十几名守卫和监狱工作人员代表其他被拘留者写信，包括 Julio 和 Trung。在无限期拘留两年半后，现在 53 岁的 Victor 被释放了，监狱里的某人帮他在一家小型当地海鲜餐厅找了一份厨师工作。Victor 仍然在守卫的周一晚上垒球比赛中志愿提供他的烹饪技巧。
In July of last year, the INS agreed to release Trung, after four years in indefinite detention. His family came up with the $15,000 bond. The INS determined he was no longer a danger or a flight risk. Trung had expected to get out on a Friday, but an INS agent came by two days early and told Trung to pack his stuff. He wasn't quite ready to leave, though. He first wanted to pass along some of the computerized records he'd been keeping for the jail's education programs.
去年 7 月，移民局同意释放 Trung，在无限期拘留四年后。他的家人筹集了 15,000 美元的保释金。移民局确定他不再构成危险或潜逃风险。Trung 本来预计在周五出去，但一名移民局特工提前两天过来告诉 Trung 收拾东西。但他还没有准备好离开。他首先想传达他一直在为监狱教育计划保留的一些计算机记录。
To tell you the truth, I told the officer, "Hey, I'm not even finished with my work here yet." At that time, I was so involved with the GED stuff up there, and I took care of a lot of the paperwork and stuff. And I wanted to show them everything before I go, so--
老实说，我告诉警官，“嘿，我在这边的工作还没做完呢。”当时，我太投入于那边的 GED 工作了，我处理了很多文书工作之类的。我想在离开前向他们展示一切，所以——
Let me get this straight. So here they tell you you're free, and you say, "No, I want to stay in jail for a few extra days so I can help out the guards and the teachers here."
让我搞清楚。所以他们告诉你你自由了，你说，“不，我想在监狱里多待几天，这样我就能帮助那里的守卫和老师。”
Yeah. I want to go home, but then I also want to finish my job before I leave.
是的。我想回家，但我也想在离开前完成我的工作。
?] Tran and I got very close. We worked for a long time together.
Tran 和我变得非常亲近。我们一起工作了很长时间。
Again, Virginia [? Escahito. ?]
又是 Virginia Escahito。
?] And still we see each other, and he tries to stop by once in a while. And I just-- I love him. And there's several other of the guys that write to me and send me letters. And I've kept every piece of mail from them. I've got it, too.
我们仍然见面，他试着偶尔顺道过来。我只是——我爱他。还有其他几个人给我写信。我保存了他们寄来的每一封邮件。我也留着它。
Virginia goes into her bedroom and emerges rather excitedly bearing a shallow plastic bin. She kneels and spills the contents onto the floor. She's held onto everything. There are a pile of letters from former INS detainees and trinkets made by the Cubans.
Virginia 走进卧室，兴奋地拿着一个浅塑料盒出来。她跪下，把里面的东西倒在地板上。她保存了一切。有一堆来自前移民局被拘留者的信件和古巴人制作的小玩意儿。
?] All of these are nothing but handkerchiefs.
这些全都是手帕。
Trung leans back on the couch, calmly smiling. Virginia's now a police officer in a nearby town, and she's still in uniform. She goes to sit next to him and pokes him in the ribs. "I'm glad you've put on some weight," she says, giggling. She teases him about the female inmates in the jail.
Trung 靠在沙发上，平静地笑着。Virginia 现在是附近城镇的一名警察，她仍然穿着制服。她坐到他旁边，戳了戳他的肋骨。“我很高兴你长胖了一些，”她说，咯咯笑着。她取笑他监狱里的女囚犯。
?] They would try to grab or something, and I'd go, don't you--
她们会试图抓住什么的，我就说，不要你——
Soon, another former guard, Mike Martinez, arrives. He and Virginia ask Trung about Julio, Trung's old cellmate. The day before, Julio had marked his fifth anniversary at the Victoria jail. It's possible he could be there for the rest of his life. In the eyes of the INS, if a detainee's crimes are serious enough that he seems like a threat to society, it doesn't matter how long he serves or what he does in jail. It's unlikely he'll be released.
很快，另一名前守卫 Mike Martinez 到了。他和 Virginia 向 Trung 询问 Julio，Trung 的老牢友。前一天，Julio 标志着他在维多利亚监狱的五周年纪念日。他有可能余生都待在那里。在移民局看来，如果被拘留者的罪行严重到他看起来对社会构成威胁，他服刑多久或他在监狱里做什么并不重要。他不太可能被释放。
Julio has submitted testimonials from jail staff but the INS has turned him down, possibly because his offenses are among the worst from the INS's point of view. He has five convictions for smuggling illegal aliens. Trung visits him on occasion, and recently sent him a gift, one which, intentional or not, bore a message of sorts.
Julio 提交了监狱工作人员的证词，但移民局拒绝了他，这可能是因为他的罪行在移民局看来是最糟糕的。他有五项走私非法外国人的定罪。Trung 偶尔探望他，最近送了他一份礼物，无论是否有意，这都带有某种信息。
I bought Julio a big duffel bag so in case-- when he does get released, he'll have a bag to carry. Because I, myself, when I got released, I didn't have duffel bags. I had two boxes full of legal documents. And I was picked up from here by immigration and taken to San Antonio, and I had to catch a Greyhound back to Houston. And here I am, carrying two plastic container boxes walking around, with old clothing, you know? So I felt sorry for Julio, so I ended up buying a duffel bag and some other stuff for him.
我给 Julio 买了一个大行李袋，以防万一——当他获释时，他会有一个袋子可以携带。因为我本人，当我获释时，我没有行李袋。我有两个装满法律文件的箱子。我被移民局从这里接走带到圣安东尼奥，我不得不搭乘灰狗巴士回休斯顿。这里是我，带着两个塑料容器盒四处走，穿着旧衣服，你知道吗？所以我为 Julio 感到难过，所以我最终给他买了一个行李袋和其他一些东西。
Trung himself is in a state of limbo. If he gets in any kind of legal trouble, the INS could send him back to prison, and if and when Vietnam reaches an expatriation agreement with the US, Trung would be deported. This experience has-- and perhaps it was inevitable-- altered Trung's perception of himself. He now considers himself Vietnamese, not American. He reads a weekly Vietnamese newspaper and listens to Vietnamese music. He only eats at Vietnamese restaurants. He sends money when he can to his grandmother who still lives in Saigon. With the exception of those he met at Victoria, he only hangs out with other Vietnamese immigrants, and for the first time, he's dating a Vietnamese woman.
Trung 本人处于一种不稳定的状态。如果他遇到任何类型的法律麻烦，移民局可能会把他送回监狱，如果越南与美国达成遣返协议，Trung 将被遣返。这种经历已经——也许是不可避免的——改变了 Trung 对自己的看法。他现在认为自己是越南人，而不是美国人。他阅读一份每周的越南报纸，听越南音乐。他只在越南餐馆吃饭。他尽可能地给仍住在西贡的祖母寄钱。除了他在维多利亚遇到的人，他只与其他的越南移民交往，而且这是他第一次与一名越南女性约会。
I do. I finally realized that I'm not that American kid that I once thought I was. That status has been taken away from me, that, hey, you're just a visitor here. And that this door can shut at any given time, so don't have too much fun and get adapted to it.
我是的。我终于意识到我不是那个我曾经认为自己是的那种美国孩子。那种身份被剥夺了，嘿，你只是这里的访客。而且这扇门随时都可能关闭，所以不要太开心并适应它。
Virginia's journey has been a quieter but no less profound one.
Virginia 的旅程是一个更安静但也同样深刻的旅程。
?] Before I worked back in the jail, I wouldn't question anything. I'd go along with, OK, this is right. This is the law. This is America. This is the way it should be. And now I'm going, uh-uh, there's something wrong here. Because it was just a shock to me, what they do to the INS inmates. Yes, they've made mistakes but they've paid for those mistakes already. Sometimes I think, who do we think we are? God? To keep these people up here, like this-- it's not right.
在我在监狱工作之前，我不会质疑任何事情。我会随大流，好吧，这是对的。这是法律。这是美国。这就是它应该的样子。现在我心想，嗯，这里有什么不对劲。因为那对我来说真是个冲击，他们对移民局被拘留者所做的一切。是的，他们犯了错误，但他们已经为那些错误付出了代价。有时候我想，我们以为我们是谁？上帝？把这些人关在这里，像这样——这不对。
Virginia is not alone. When I was at the Victoria jail visiting Julio and the other detainees, a deputy sheriff who looked to be about 50 came up to me. "Are you the one visiting the INS guys?" He asked, rather gruffly. I told him I was. He smiled. "I just wanted to shake your hand," he said, "and say thank you." Thank you from a guard for doing a story on his prisoners. "I do feel for these individuals," he told me. "After all," he said, "they've served their time."
Virginia 并不孤单。当我在维多利亚监狱探望 Julio 和其他被拘留者时，一个看起来大约 50 岁的副警长走到我面前。“你是那个探望移民局的人吗？”他相当粗鲁地问。我告诉他我是。他笑了。“我只是想和你握个手，”他说，“并说声谢谢。”感谢一名守卫报道他的囚犯的故事。“我确实为这些人感到难过，”他告诉我。“毕竟，”他说，“他们已经服完了刑。”
Alex Kotlowitz is the author of There Are No Children Here and other books. Just this month, the Supreme Court agreed to hear two cases of these indefinite detainees, people who are in jail with no country to go back to.
Alex Kotlowitz 是《这里没有孩子》和其他书籍的作者。就在这个月，最高法院同意审理两起关于这些无限期被拘留者的案件，人们在没有国家可以回去的情况下被关在监狱里。
Well, our program was produced by Blue Chevigny and myself, with Alex Blumberg and Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Hillary Frank.
嗯，我们的节目是由 Blue Chevigny 和我本人制作的，Alex Blumberg 和 Julie Snyder 协助。Todd Bachmann 和 Hillary Frank 提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who, from the beginning, felt this way about the fact that we quote him at the end of each and every show--
WBEZ 的管理监督由 Torey Malatia 负责，他从一开始就对我们在每个节目结束时引用他有这种感觉——
I thought it was stupid and cruel then. I still think it is.
我当时就觉得它愚蠢而残忍。我现在仍然觉得是。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是 Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。